Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain an episode called “Hi-so”
from a Thai mystery thriller anthology series
“Girl From Nowhere.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
In the opening scene, we are introduced to
a prestigious high school in Thailand. An
affiliate of the school is giving a tour to a new
student named Nanno. She shows her every classroom
and tells Nanno the name of the parents who
donated for the rooms to be well-equipped.
It is clear that the school runs on donations from
the parents. The rich students are respected while
the poor ones are made fun of. Nanno asks if
she is allowed to pay to own one of the rooms
in the school. The woman takes her words into
consideration and gives her an old classroom
in turn for money. Nanno then changes the
classroom into her personal office.
Somewhere else, the son of a millionaire
businessman, Dino, brings bags full of
gifts from the UK for his friends. He had gone to
visit his parents who live there. Alongside Dino,
To was also in the UK for a trip. His friends had
placed a bet on who would bring them more gifts,
and Dino wins. The friends unknowingly
compete against each other in terms of wealth.
Dino is the unsaid leader of the group
and the wealthiest one among them.
To asks him why he didn’t meet him when they were
in the same city, to which Dino replies that he
wanted to spend time with his family.
To is infuriated that his friends like Dino
better than him and is ashamed that he is
not as wealthy. It is evident that the group
loves Dino just for his money. He is aware of
the fact but doesn’t mind them using him.
The group finds out that a new student bought
an entire classroom for herself on her first
day at school. Dino finally has a competitor which
he is not happy about. As they talk about Nanno,
she enters the classroom and affirms that
she did in fact buy a room in the school.
According to her, she is opening her own company
that will help the students get anything they want
in turn for money. She hands them all her
business cards, claiming that her company’s
motto is that money can buy everything.
Following that, the teacher walks in and
hands them all the results of the last test.
Dino, as usual, gets the best grades out of them.
Meanwhile, Pop is mad because he scored only a
2.24 GPA when he had to cross 3.0 to get a new
motorbike from his father. He complains about
life being unfair when Nanno offers to help him
through her company. She brings them to her office
and asks Pop for 15000 BATH for the service. Since it is
pretty cheap compared to the motorcycle he wants,
he decides to give her the money. Moreover, the
group wants to test if she is telling the truth.
After confirming that the money is paid in full,
Nanno asks for his test result and shreds it using
a paper shredder. The group is shocked but then,
Nanno prints out a brand new paper with a better
score. It looks identical to the others so Pop’s
parents wouldn’t notice that it is fake. He
thanks her, happy with the results. Nanno
claims that she can do many other things
for them. When asked what kind of things,
she smiles and says anything. Starting that
day, her business flourishes quickly. A crowd
of students lines up in front of her office
with money, asking her for several favors.
One day, a guy asks Nanno to teach his
ex-girlfriend a lesson for cheating on him.
That evening her new boyfriend is beaten to death
by some thugs. Similarly, another guy asks for a
girlfriend and gets one, thanks to her company.
One day after class, Nanno questions Dino why
he hasn’t asked her for her services till now.
She thinks it is strange that he has no problems
in his life. The others claim that he is filthy
rich, his parents are never home, and his grades
are good. Since his life is basically perfect,
he doesn’t need her help. Pop even claims that if
Nanno has a problem, she must come to Dino because
he has a solution to everything. Then, a girl
named Whan mentions that she needs Dino’s help
to create a fake teacher’s letter to her parents.
She wants to go on an overnight trip outside
Thailand but doesn’t want her parents to know.
The guys like the idea and join in on it.
Soon, they start to plan a trip to Japan.
When they ask Dino to join, he claims that
he is tired of taking so many trips abroad
and just wants to be home for now. The others try
to convince him to join them but he doesn’t budge.
Nanno knows something about him is off. To find
out, she suggests they go to Dino’s house for
dinner. Since it is a massive villa that has a
swimming pool, a home theater, a snooker room,
a golf room, and many other facilities, the group
is sure to enjoy the stay much more than if they
travel abroad. However, Dino doesn’t want them
in his house, afraid that they will get drunk and
break expensive things in it. Pop promises
to take responsibility for all the damages
and urges him to invite them for only a night.
When he still doesn’t agree, they get irritated
and ask him if he considers them his friends. Dino
doesn’t want them to be upset and agrees to let
them stay for a single night. After school ends,
he gets inside his car and tells the driver the
address to his house. When he reaches there, it
is revealed that Dino’s parents are small business
owners who work hard to send him to a prestigious
school. When he first came into the school,
he saw how only the rich kids had friends and
lied to them about being wealthy. With time, he
had to keep up with the lie by renting cars to the
school and buying them food from his fake foreign
trips. This is the reason why he didn’t meet
To during his last “trip” to the UK. Similarly,
he didn’t want to invite his friends to his
extravagant villa, because he doesn’t have one.
Dino’s parents are normal people who want nothing
but his happiness. They are unaware of their son’s
shenanigans and think that his generous friends
drop him home in their fancy cars every day.
They never let Dino help them in household
work, saying that he should focus on his
studies instead. That day, Dino is tense because
if he doesn’t bring his friends to a massive villa
the next day, they will know that he has been
lying to them for several years. After coming
this far with the lies, he cannot step back. He
gets a text from Nanno in the group chat asking
him at what time they should come to his house.
Dino is thinking of a way to avoid the topic but
his friends start to talk about what they are
going to wear to the dinner. As the conversation
proceeds, he cannot say no to them.
His only way is to ask Nanno for help.
He calls her and tells her that he wants a
house for the next day. When asked why he
cannot take them to his original house, he still
insists that he doesn’t want them to break the
expensive decorations. Nanno promises to keep it
a secret and agrees to help him with his problem.
However, she charges two hundred
thousand baht for the fake mansion.
Dino doesn’t have that much money to waste for a
single night but he hopes to manage it. When his
parents are distracted packing boxes for their
business, he steals his father’s purse. As he
is about to bring the card out, he overhears
his parents talking about loan sharks who have
been bothering them every day. If they do not pay
them two hundred thousand baht by the next week,
they have threatened to kill them. The couple
is relieved because they have earned enough
this month to pay off the loans. Dino puts the
card back after listening to their conversation.
But then, a vision of his friends calling him a
liar and a cheat makes him take it out again.
When his parents fall asleep, he sneaks out of
the house and withdraws money from the ATM. On
returning home, he encounters his father
and is almost caught. The next morning,
Dino wakes up to his parents on a phone call with
the bank, complaining about the theft. When the
phone operator suggests someone from the family
must have taken it out, Dino’s father refuses to
believe it. Dino simply walks out of the house
and meets Nanno in front of his mansion for the
day. When asked if he likes it, he comments
that it is a bit smaller than his house.
Later, the entire group arrives at the house
for dinner. Dino proudly sits on the sofa,
pretending like the expensive cigar and the
in-house golf course is normal to him. Then,
Nanno suggests they drink whiskey. She is
set on calling the maids to serve them,
almost as if she has planned something.
When the housemaids arrive in the lobby,
Dino is shocked to see that it is his parents.
They have taken the job to earn more money to pay
off the loan. They recognize their son but do
not call him out in front of his friends. Dino
can hardly say anything when Nanno suggests they
look at his parents’ pictures on the internet.
On finding them, she also comments that he
resembles the house servants, more than he
resembles his parents. Dino’s mother helps him,
claiming that he looks like his grandfather.
Following that, they go to the dining room and
are served a full-course restaurant-style meal.
When they drink the whiskey, they realize that it
is actually fruit juice. Pop lashes out at Dino’s
father, calling him an idiot. The man apologizes
and says that they shouldn’t be drinking at
their age. This makes Pop even more furious. He
emphasizes that Dino’s father is just a servant,
asking him to act like one. After being insulted,
the man simply serves them the drink.
To stir the awkwardness, Nanno suggests they
smoke weed as well. Dino tries to stop them,
saying that his parents might find out
but the group doesn’t listen. To fit in,
he also smokes while his parents watch him in
disappointment. Moments later, Pop asks for wine
but Dino’s father refuses to serve it since they
have already had too much to drink. Pop threatens
to get him fired and insults him yet again. Scared
of him, Dino’s mother serves them the wine even
when the father disagrees. She accidentally drops
it on Whan who accuses her of doing it on purpose.
Pop gets up from his seat, ready to fight them but
Dino stops him. He calms everyone down and asks
his friends to go to another room. For a minute,
he is left alone with his parents but he walks
away when his mother tries to talk to him.
Following that, the group goes to a study room
while complaining about the rude servants. They
want to do something fun to lighten the mood
when Nanno shows them a revolver she found on
a shelf. Pop loads a single bullet and bets two
hundred thousand baht on the person who gets shot.
The group joins in and bets two hundred thousand
baht each. The person to get shot in the arm
will receive more than one million baht, so Dino
doesn’t want to give up the chance. Pop goes first
but isn’t shot, similarly, three of them press
the trigger with the gun to their arm, but they do
not get shot as well. When it is Nanno’s turn, she
points to her head but doesn’t get shot either.
At last, it is Dino’s turn. He is about to shoot
himself when his father stops him. He yells at
the kids to be more responsible with their lives
because their parents love them. An enraged Pop
hits him with a golf club and knocks him out.
Before the group can react, Dino’s mother
interferes and starts to scold them.
Pop hits her with the back of the revolver and
knocks her out as well. Dino freezes in shock but
he still doesn’t do anything to help his parents.
Nanno starts to laugh maniacally while the others
look at the maids in horror. In the following
scene, Dino walks to his house to see that
his parents are having dinner. Their faces are
covered in injuries that were inflicted by Pop.
They do not talk about the events of the day and
call him to have dinner. A flashback shows us
that after coming back to consciousness, they
were given thirty-five hundred thousand baht
to keep their mouths shut. Following that,
we see the family having dinner peacefully.
The camera pans towards the bag of money they
received earlier.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.